What I eat in a day as a mom who eats an ancestral diet
and as someone who avoids seed oils,
artificial sugars,
dyes, and preservatives at all costs.
I start my morning off with a glass of filtered water
and lemon juice from my tree.
Then I make a pour over coffee with organic
mold free beans and a good amount of raw pasteurized cream.
At 9:00am I whip up a batch of sourdough discard blueberry muffins
which fermented
overnight to neutralize phytic acid and enzyme inhibitors.
While those bake
I make 100% grass fed beef breakfast sausages
and some eggs for my backyard pasta raised chickens.
Then I take my birthright prenatal and hormone balancing supplement
which I love because they're made with ancestral real foods
like raw 100% grass fed beef liver and colostrum
about fish row and oysters.
At 10:00am I prepared a heritage breed hold chicken
that had been pasture raised and slaughtered on my parents farm.
Season with unrefined sea salt,
pepper, herbs,
garlic and onion.
I let this bake in the oven at 300 degrees Fahrenheit
until dinner time.
Made myself a rock of your smoothie at two PM
with my homegrown frozen peaches,
tamarillos and garnished with bee pollen.
Later that afternoon
I whipped up a raw cheesecake
using homemade raw cream cheese from my parents farm,
eggs from my chickens, and a nut and date crust.
We had dinner at 6
which was a chicken noodle soup
topped with homemade pickled Radish and rock crout
and some avocado
followed by a slice of raw cheesecake.
It was so delicious.